hey guys how's it going so I've been
doing a little bit of research about the
new iPhone 7 there's been tons of rumors
out you guys have tweeted me a bunch of
things so I thought that I would just go
through and look at some of the rumors
and we can chat about it together in the
comments one of the biggest things that
I've seen as far as the iPhone 7 is
concerned that they completely want to
remove the headphone jack crazy I know
but really it's not that crazy because
in the history of Apple they have done
some crazy things they're always first
to push the envelope they're always like
you know what we don't want to have a
floppy Drive anymore oh you want that CD
ROM drive nope gone you don't need it
and usually I have said but you're wrong
I need said thing I need that CD ROM
drive and no you don't need it but will
removing the headphone jack here on the
iPhone 7 be a little bit too soon for
some people I don't know but the good
thing about not having a headphone jack
is that they'll be able to completely
change the design of the phone and make
it a thinner I don't know how much
thinner you're going to want to make
this because if this gets any thinner
it's going to become a weapon you're
going to hurt yourself someone is going
to get injured this is already really
pretty thin this is this is a good size
this is great I I love this
phone so much but I thought today we
would go through and just look at some
iPhone 7 rumors and see what people are
chatting about I also saw there was a
few prototypes where it's a
completely this whole front
screen is a screen it's all touchcreen
kind of like the Samsung Edge where you
can see notifications and stuff on the
edge of your screen I don't think
Apple's going to do that I don't I don't
I don't I don't think they're going to
do it but I could be wrong I could be
wrong I don't know what they're going to
do so let's do some searching let's go
hit up
google.com have you guys heard of this
website it's really great you can search
stuff I actually remember the first time
that I used Google it kind of kind of
did blow my mind I was also kind of busy
asking Jeeves if you guys remember
Jeeves great guy iPhone 7 leak reveals
biggest design changes okay Forbes
pretty uh okay we're not doing any of
this we're not what is this apple
Insider says that they are going to be
replacing the headphone jack with a
second speaker this will the iPhone 7
stereo audio for the first time in
history oh
no I sometimes like to take my phone in
the shower which is probably a really
terrible thing and I don't recommend
doing it and I will always sit my phone
up like this and then water ends up
seeping into my phone so now that's
going to allow for
two speakers to get destroyed instead of
just one I have a feeling that Apple's
probably going to say bye-bye to the
lightning cables because they're going
to want to switch to USBC it's also said
that the space saved from emitting the
headphone jack will enable Apple to up
the iPhone 7 with wireless charging
waterproofing and bigger battery I don't
think wireless charging is going to be
100% necessary if they are able to
somehow waterproof this phone I would be
really excited and the bigger battery
please please please please even though
I have a phone the size of a
television the battery still doesn't
last let's see what else we can find
iPhone
7 expand the use okay iPhone 7 okay
hello sh can you is this an ad what's
this iPhone 7 trailer is this a joke
this is probably a joke yeah let's let's
pop this
open holy moly that's loud
it looks good water resistant cool that
would be nice I would I would appreciate
it big it's
tall I like those Circle buttons that's
a good idea the rose gold I feel like
wasn't as successful of a launch what
are these I will not buy Beats by Dre
headphones if this is what I have to use
I'm going to I'm going to be severely
upset I won't use them I will not use
them
this looks good the problem with the
charging pads is H actually I can't
think of a problem with one them right
now I like get those headphones off my
screen oh Force touch home button with
taptic feedback okay this is actually a
pretty good pretty good fake trailer I'm
into
it look at your
body iPhone developed by
Apple cool this is a really good video
who are you Concepts iPhone my God I
love you I'm beyond iPhone 6 concept
work okay well we're over the iPhone 6
at this point but you guys are amazing
here's my problem with wireless
headphones when I'm on an airplane I
want people to see this plugged into
phone and know that means do not disturb
that is a very key sign of saying hello
I'm listening to some really fantastic
music right now and I would rather not
be disturbed here's an article about
Apple that is unlikely to include noise
cancelling headphones with the iPhone 7
the amount of money that they probably
could have saved by not including the
white earbuds in any of their products
would be quite astonishing I would like
to see a show of I can't say hands but a
show of comments but how many of you
guys actually use the white earbuds that
came with any of your Apple products
because they do not fit in my ears
whatsoever I have tried every single
time I've even tried this new design
that they recently uh announced not too
long well this was a while ago at this
point don't work they they just fall
right out the best headphones that I've
ever found I live and swear and I will
die by these headphones are the Bose
headphones I'll put a link in the
description if you guys want to check
them out all right Amazon Bose
headphones so these are the one the in
ear these are the only ones that
actually work and stay in my ears anyway
we just got sidetracked I'm going to go
back here we already looked at that one
other rumors have suggested that apple
is preparing a Bluetooth solution Okay
blah blah blah blah what's
this truly wireless earbuds that are
actually good show us what you got what
you really really
got these I will lose these in 5 seconds
they need to be connected together I'm
only going to end up I'm going to lose
one ear and then I'm not going to be
able to hear stereo Apple will use a
simple codec to introduce lightning Port
audio to the iPhone 7 followed by more
advanced noise cancelling codec next
year it says but it would be kind of
cool to see lightning cable headphones
it'll be kind of interesting to see how
many people jump on that bandwagon as
far as like third party goes there's a
really good chance that they could also
have an adapter so it could be just a
lightning cable with a port for your
headphone jack but then that's going to
be kind of annoying look how
little look how little 5 in display but
only 3
mm thick I'm going to lose the phone I'm
going to lose my headphones I'm going to
lose the phone touchless button-free
handset thinnest smoothest handset ever
let's talk about something other than
the headphones shall we iPhone 7 camera
iPhone 7 packed with flush rear camera
thinnest iPhone will have no more camera
Rings issue that'll be kind of nice
because when I don't have a case on my
phone which is pretty rare at this point
uh the raised camera always kind of
makes me a little bit nervous cuz when
you set it down it doesn't lay flush to
the ground or the table cuz why am I
putting my phone on the ground I don't
know expected to be released in three
versions iPhone 7 iPhone 7 plus and
iPhone 7 Pro holy CRA iPhone 7 Pro are
you crazy second variant is expected to
have a dual camera set up while the
third one will more likely be a
fablet fabulous also rumored that they
are currently working on a new Force
sense techn technology to be
incorporated into iPhone 7 so it might
have the latest feature of the Flawless
3D touch I don't really use 3D touch
that often to be completely honest I
don't really ever use it I sometimes
accidentally use it when I'm trying to
view live pictures that people sent and
it sometimes doesn't work am I crazy or
the live pictures sometimes don't work
properly I push it it either doesn't
play or sometimes it plays then I start
pushing so hard on my phone that I feel
like I'm going to break it and then I
can finally view the live photo I'm not
sure let's see what else we've got let's
talk about this camera with two lenses
because this could be interesting here's
why it's a great idea what I liked about
this camera on the iPhone 6s is it did
introduced this dual flash which made a
huge difference especially in skin tones
and when you're taking photos with a
flash because it does a really great job
of sort of adjusting to different
lighting situations and it made a huge
difference so let's see what we've got
in store Apple spent 20 million buying a
small technology firm called Lynx they
built miniature appature cameras
designed for mobile devices it allows
cameras to have a better low light
performance fantastic there's two
sensors trying to gather as much light
information as
possible give smartphone the ability to
capture depth information because just
like your human eye they see the scene
in Stereo
H H 3D image
capturing oh snap twin camera every
single feature sounds like something
Apple would try to sell by blah blah BL
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah okay this is one of the images
that I saw before was sort of just this
whole screen display so the whole
freaking front of your
phone is a
screen um they've been talking about the
iPad Air 3 they've also been rumoring a
4in iPhone which they're talking about
right here what do you what have we got
I I don't know what do you guys think do
you think a smaller iPhone is something
that we need or are we at the point that
people have adjusted to this because
even a lot of my friends still don't
have the iPhone 6 plus they actually
prefer the six that's real thin that
looks good that looks nice I like that
look I just want to look good for you
good for
you well that looks like everything that
I see here so I think we'll probably
find out pretty soon what it is that
they are going to be announcing I'm
excited because you guys know that I'm
obsessed with my my phone like I I'm so
obsessed and I wish I wasn't but I am I
do everything on here I hardly ever
actually use a computer unless I'm doing
any type of video editing the problem is
I still do need a computer and I need
one that's pretty powerful even editing
raw images and especially editing
starting now I've been working on doing
some more 4K footage and the computer
that I'm running right now it's not
powerful enough and I broke down and I
got a Mac Pro and I'm sort of upset
about it because I know that Apple's
probably going to announce something new
coming up very soon I'm going to be like
shoot no I just got a Mac Pro but I
can't wait because I can't edit on this
computer anymore it's so incredibly slow
but this video is about the iPhone 7 and
that's all I've got for you today let me
know what you guys think in the comments
below what are you looking forward to
what do you like what do you don't like
and which rumors do you think will
actually be true see you guys in the
next video peace dog is cute cakes in
the
oven let's do this time
[Music]
out